[Music]
did you ever wonder why some coins have
tiny ridges on them and other coins are
smooth
well what if i told you those ridges are
the direct result of the collision of
two massive objects known as neutron
stars billions of years ago that's right
and today on this episode of into the
impossible i'll explain why
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
here's a picture of a very very famous
rabbi his name is rabbi simco barnum of
fajista he taught his students everyone
must have two pockets with a note in
each one so that he can reach in to one
or the other depending on the need
when feeling lowly and depressed
discouraged and disconsolate
one note would read the universe was
created for my sake
but when feeling haughty high and mighty
one should have another note in the
other pocket that says i am nothing but
dust and ashes
and sometimes you reach into your
pockets and you feel the jingling of
coins
and some of those coins have ridges on
them or flutes and today we're going to
explain why those flutes got there and
actually those flutes can remind us of
these two expressions that the universe
was created for us and that were nothing
but dust and ashes here's how we know
that the universe is not centered on us
but it's helpful to act as if it's so at
least in a diagram like this taken from
my book losing the nobel prize
this shows our view of the cosmos as if
it were a pristine looking glass that we
can spy through and not have anything
impede our sights back perhaps to the
origin of the universe itself
however the universe as i point out in
that very same cosmic memoir is a very
dusty place
very dirty smoggy place not unlike my
neighbors to the north in los angeles no
offense the question is what is that
dust and what can that dust do for us
turns out dust has been a very key
player in most of our cosmic phenomena
that occur on earth and even flowing
through our own veins we take a really
macroscopic look at the evolution of the
universe from the big bang to the
formation of stars and galaxies to
planets we increase in complexity until
we get to the formation of molecules of
chemistry and then from chemistry
perhaps to biology from biology to
conscious beings such as ourselves
we don't know exactly how either the
process of the big bang unfolded or how
the process of abiogenesis took place
nor how the problem of consciousness
emerges these are the famous chicken or
egg problems that i'd love to discuss
darwin in fact wrote about the lack
the missing ingredient
describing the origin of life remember
his book was called the origin of
species he said it is no valid objection
that science as yet throws no light on
the far higher problem of the essence or
origin of life it is mere rubbish
thinking at the present of the origin of
life one might as well think of the
origin of matter but of course we know a
great deal about the origin of matter we
know big bang nucleosynthesis we've
talked about the formation of the
elements we've talked about the
processes by which we come to understand
the formation of every element on the
periodic table coming from either the
big bang and the lightest elements on
the periodic table of hydrogen helium
lithium and their isotopes all the way
up to the formation of elements in stars
via the work of my late great colleagues
jeff burbidge margaret burbidge and
their collaborators willie fowler and
fred hoyle
so
it's not rubbish to think of the origin
of matter so maybe charlie was wrong
so how could life form
well first of all we have to define what
is life but generally scientists agree
that life has several characteristics
including the ability to acquire and use
energy to metabolize it to grow and to
behave in such a way as to forecast or
predict sources of energy
we know that life requires information
storage the presence of a genome that
specifies the expression of those
genetic characteristics and what's known
as a phenotype we know that life must
reproduce or else it would stop at a one
time off affair and that wouldn't be any
fun
and so the ability to reproduce progeny
of the same type is quite crucial to the
propagation of life
and we also know one of the most
powerful forces in the in the life cycle
is the evolution by natural selection
the ability to change and adapt to
environments to improve the capabilities
of energy and
acquisition and reproduction so all
those three primordial things depend in
some sense on evolution at the scale of
adaptation to environment so there's
this there's this interplay between the
planet and the materials that are
inorganic and not alive and those that
are organic and can lead to living
organisms
now one of the first people to speculate
how life could have gotten kicked off
from pure chemistry to biology was again
charles darwin he wrote it is often said
that the conditions on the first
production of a living being are now
present which could have been present so
all those conditions were present he
said but if and oh what a big if he said
we could conceive of some warm little
pond with all sorts of ammonia and
phosphoric salts with light with heat
with electricity present that a protein
compound would be chemically formed
ready to undergo still more complex
changes so we think of proteins as
expressing things that can then later
lead to the production of other living
things and other proteins but the
problem again of chicken or egg arises
you need proteins to produce proteins so
how did proteins come about this is a
great mystery
but some of the first investigations
were undertaken by the late great uh
harold uri and his and his graduate
student stanley miller who became a
great scientist in his own right and our
chemistry department shown in this image
here is named yuri hall after harold
erie so they did a famous experiment in
1952 reproducing what they thought were
the conditions like darwin's little pond
some conditions representative of the
early earth with instead of phosphoric
salts they had ammonia and other
chemical compounds they added heat and
light into this very cleanly carefully
prepared chemical apparatus with just
the right heat at just the right time
and just the right electric discharges
and they did find certain complex carb
carbohydrates and other
amino acids that were formed urea and
formaldehyde and things like that and
they discovered that you could produce
it from a very simple
prebiotic
compounds you could add heat energy and
get out not proteins not dna but some
chemicals that are precursors building
blocks like amino acids that are
necessary but not sufficient to create
life so we have this kind of warm little
pond we have yet to create a dna and
then create a biologist springing out of
this compound but origin of life
research continues to this day so big
questions that we've talked about on
this channel which came first the dna or
the rna we've talked about proteins
we've talked about astrobiology and life
maybe coming from another planet as fred
hoyle called panspermia the spreading of
genetic material throughout the universe
but that doesn't answer the question of
the ultimate origin of life on earth
we've talked about problems of
fine-tuning on how the genetic code is a
store of information and according to uh
dr stephen meyer and others uh that
information requires some forethought
some preconceived lower entropy state
which then evolves and he of course
associates it with a mind with a god in
his book return of the god hypothesis
now
the question of whether or not life
could have been seeded from outer space
doesn't again answer the question of the
origin of life itself so how do you get
from chemistry to biology that is a huge
leap for which we have no way to to
explain at present of course it's a
fascinating subject that we
should and continue to study in great
depth we've talked about life um
discovered on other planets and perhaps
on our planet it could be that cosmic
dust these tiny particles that pervade
our entire cosmos on every scale from
the planet
people your toddler all the way up to
interstellar medium and even beyond
these grains of dust that are leftovers
from explosions in the cosmos whether of
supernovae or other cataclysmic events
from combinations and collisions of
neutron stars for example that were that
we'll get to so when we find objects how
do we know they actually came from space
so i often give out to lucky winners
that subscribe to different giveaways on
my channel macroscopic meteorites chunks
of outer space material that landed on
earth and were collected predominantly
from a single fall in uh in argentina
called the campodius yellow but how do
you know it's not just some expensive
piece of rock that somebody's you know
tricked me into buying well you have to
cut it open and due to the diffusion and
the different of different uh atoms it's
actually easier to tell that a iron or
nickel meteorite a metallic meteorite
was formed in space because these
patterns only form from objects formed
in space they came from some asteroid
which fragmented and then broke apart
but it had this crystal these crystal
boundaries that are shown in these
patterns here so meteors come and go
they smash into the earth the most
well-preserved one in all of the
planet's surface is in arizona media
crater near winslow arizona it is almost
a perfect example exemplar of what a
meteor impact would look like
this occurred we think about 50 000
years ago i always point out how lucky
it was that the meteor struck right next
to the gift shop that was just
unbelievable timing and luck now what if
it was near new york city here's an
artist's picture i found on the web
somewhere that shows what such damage
would do god forbid if it landed in a
major metropolitan area there are of
course undersea uh meteor strikes here's
one the chiksalab crater in the north
part of the yucatan peninsula it's 180
kilometers wide so it's just enormously
bigger than even the meteor crater on
earth thankfully it's under the ocean
maybe not that because it'll be kind of
cool to see it
but it is dated to the same period of
time this cretaceous tertiary boundary
period
and is sometimes called the kt boundary
and that period has been dated all the
way around the earth and it's about 66
million years ago we think it was dated
and responsible rather to for the
extinction of the dinosaurs so as neil
degrasse tyson past guests on the show i
said it's too bad the dinosaurs didn't
have a great space program because they
could have maybe done something about
these interlopers that do come and
destroy entire species of the most
massive animals on earth and perhaps
that was fortuitous you know if nothing
else because now we exist and maybe we
wouldn't maybe we would there were
mammals back then but we don't know for
sure how the evolutionary tree would
have been affected via the presence at
the same time of dinosaurs and hominins
so that's just a counterfactual history
that we can never know uh the true
result of
gandhi said the seeker after truth
should be humbler than the dust the
world
crushes the dust
under its feet but the seeker after
truth should so humble himself that even
the dust could crush him
only then and not until then will he
have a glimpse of truth
now how does this all connect
to our original purpose of digging into
our pockets and being humbled or
elevated by the notion that we are
essentially dust and ashes or we are the
reason that the entire universe was
created well it has to do with these
flutes or ridges on coins so there's a
connection between isaac newton the
father of calculus and universal
gravitation and the ridges on coins
because actually old eike spent a lot of
time doing things other than calculus
and gravity he spent not a small amount
of time thinking of ways to torture
people who were counterfeiting coins and
he actually came up with a solution to
the problem of counterfeiting that
involves those mysterious ridges on
coins so you'll notice a coin like a
quarter or a dime which used to be made
of either a quarter ounce of silver or
tenth ounce of silver a precious metal
now is made of non-precious metals
common metal zinc and tin and things
like that but back then they were all
made a pound of uh that's where the
british pound came from pound of silver
these precious metals were very valuable
and what somebody could do is take a
coin
a circular coin and shave off
the outer edges of the coin
imperceptibly for an individual coin
removing a certain amount of silver or
gold and that amount of shavings from
the coin's rim could then be eventually
combined with many other coins shaved
rims and you would make enough material
to create a brand new coin so therefore
you'd be creating inflation you'd be
reducing the size of an actual quarter
or a dime and you'd be creating new
coins out of nothing essentially just
from grinding it down this was a big
problem this coin clipping or ways of
forgery and so he set out to both
discourage
uh using the methods of torture
available to him in the 16 and 1700s in
england but he would also look at
these other ways of technological ways
to
prevent the counterfeiting of coins via
this coin clipping method so why are
metals like silver and gold valuable and
why do we not have it on copper pennies
aren't made of copper again a zinc or
something like that why don't they have
ridges well because copper is not a
precious metal and actually this has a
rather stark and scandalous connection
to the history of the jewish people in
england in the in the middle ages in
1278 in this day of jewish history as
shown in this uh in this headline from a
few years back
all the jews of england were arrested
in a coin clipping scandal and it's
really no joke because many of them were
tortured and killed
this is long before newton
and uh if they didn't really have ways
against this and there was a lot of
anti-semitism at the time as well this
process led to the expulsion of jews for
hundreds of years
so it was really thanks to isaac
newton's innovation
to put these ridges on precious metals
on precious metal minted coins that
would be a telltale deterrent to those
trying to shave down the coin clipping
method that really got rid of this
scandal and the byproducts thereof and
allowed the jews eventually to come back
to england so it's interesting that this
character isaac newton had as one of his
many many contributions to to history
and civilization as einstein called him
the greatest contributor to western
civilization
that one of them was to effectively
allow jews and other people to live
without suspicion of this coin clipping
or counterfeiting or inflationary
practice
so with the large amounts of money isaac
newton used his role as warden of the
mint in 1696 to form a new way a new
invention of preventing the rounding of
money and making of the edges with
letters or with engravings so this is an
invention
that was quite valuable to the
prevention and deterrence of
counterfeiting so the recoinage
initiated by newton is really the reason
that this counterfeiting stopped and is
the reason you have these things in your
pocket that have ridges on them
and they come from these rare earth
elements
so in 2017 astronomers around the world
recorded this first collision that was
seen both by ligo and by optical
telescopes around the world and it was
the collision of neutron stars and these
two neutron stars came together
and uh and ignited this this massive
explosion seen really across the
universe and uh for us to see it here in
the milky way galaxy hundreds of light
years away hundreds of millions of light
years away and this collision was of two
neutron stars and neutrons are the
subatomic particles the atomic nuclei
that are the
composed of quarks and these quarks when
they come together they can
comprise either a proton or a neutron in
this case the entire star almost is
neutron-rich material and when they come
together they make objects they make
elements rather that are very rich in
neutrons and two such elements that are
like that or three such elements that
are like that are platinum gold and uh
and silver so silver is used for coins
gold two platinum lasso but still used
as a precious metal so the inspiring
collision of these neutron stars only
observed 400 years after newton's
coin minting that's the reason these are
very rare these neutron stars do not
collide very often so the rarity of it
plus it has to be eventually
incorporated in the earth's crust and
then mined and minted and forged et
cetera it's an incredibly
energy-intensive process and incredibly
rare sort of a proof of work for these
rare elements like gold platinum and
silver and so their rarity their
scarcity is the reason they must be
protected when they're used in coins and
that's the reason why
your pockets are filled with some coins
that have on them these ridges
so again can you spare a dime one side
of your pocket should have a note or
maybe you can reach in and feel that
coin and the coin will have ridges and
maybe in the other one you don't have
ridges you have a penny in there and
you'll recognize that you are nothing
but dust and ashes just like the cosmos
just like those non-precious metals like
copper or zinc but on the other one you
get the illustrious feeling that the
universe might have been made just for
you
i'm brian keating chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics at uc
san diego thank you for going into the
impossible if you enjoyed this video you
definitely want to check out this
playlist with
my cosmology friends talking about the
origin and evolution of the universe
and if you're interested in a deep dive
in the multiverse wormholes and other
exotic phenomena click here and hear my
conversation with juan maldasena of the
institute for advanced study enjoy and
don't forget to subscribe for more
amazing content
[Music]